so the book the waning of the Ottoman of
Middle Ages studied a period in between
the late 14th in the 15th century in an
area of Europe that we call a Low
Countries which is today northern France
Belgium and the Netherlands and pieces
of Germany principally the reason why we
pursued this workshop is because this
book even though it's coming up upon its
centenary almost 100 years old
is one of the most popular books in MIDI
but you medieval European history and
it's widely read throughout the world
today and in fact it's a global
bestseller it's been translated recently
over the last 15 years in Korea Japanese
and Mandarin and it could be Kennedy
because so it's continuing to be
translated into multiple languages
throughout the world the workshop
brought together a group of scholars of
the area of Europe the Low Countries
about which the book was written and
just for us to confront this very
curious phenomena which is this is one
of the best-selling books and media for
history written about a period at a time
of which were specialists and yet this
book is more popular in the general
public today than it is with specialists
in the field so we were trying to assess
why this book has such a global
popularity and why it endures as a work
of scholarship even though it's a
hundred years old
the book was dedicated to two questions
that were of central concern to the
Vista story in Johan Huizinga
one was this part of Europe the Low
Countries Belgium the Netherlands France
and parts of Germany at this period was
this period like it was in the South a
new beginning as historians of the
Italian period the Italian Renaissance
argued or was it something else and then
second to the question also the second
question was what is this significance
of the width of what the historian
hellevang Boykin saw Johan plans to -
this all has a a fundamental gap
cultural political gap
between art and literature and society
art and literature that seemed to be
centered around notions of aesthetic
beauty in the search what he called a
more perfect life and a reality of a
violent outer kilter politically
unstable society so how could you have
art on the one hand that was very
sublime and on the other hand a society
that was rent with violence and and
political problems of the highest order
and so what is remarkable about the book
is that Johan Huizinga did not use
traditional sources that historian used
at this time
he was interested in a wide or portrait
of society the way he thought he could
get at that portrait was through
literature through art through
chronicles and through a whole range of
other non-traditional sources that
historians mostly hadn't pursued and so
that he could conjure up a total social
portrait of a society he came to a
couple of conclusions he came to the
conclusion that the north of Europe at
this time was fundamentally different
from the south and that the world in
which he was studying was an endpoint
not a new point there was a culmination
of a series of centuries rather than
what people thought historians thought
the South was a new beginning their
Renaissance and second to answer a
second question this culmination was
problematic and this is why there was an
altar outer kilter society and a gulf
between art and society and that is that
the society was the society of it hadn't
reached a kind of brief breaking point
in which the normative values the values
by which people proclaim to live were
divorced from the reality of how they
lived in other words they were they were
attached to a series of suppositions and
principles and morals that were in fact
no longer what they said they were and
that there was a golf therefore between
thought aesthetics art and reality and
that golf is because of the break
between what he said was what he called
form and content and so um I think one
of the enduring importances of this book
is that he was able to create a portrait
of a very fractured and troubled society
or on the one hand you had great
aesthetics great works of art great
works of literature great works of music
and on the other hand a society that
seems to us so deeply violent and
problematic and how these two could
exist together at the same time and
that's a problem that we historians
assess that he's got perhaps wrong
factually but that as a proposition and
as a as a interpretation of the social
condition that has has intrigued people
and that people have found relevant not
only to this period but to other periods
in time including today one of the
things about this book that is really
interesting is that it has been
translated into I don't know how many
languages many many many languages it's
read all over the world and it is read
outside the Academy but the Academy ID
universities have had a terrible time
figuring out what to do with this book
and how to read it
so our workshop was focused on why it's
been so hard to take charge of for even
specialists of this period in this place
the great Burgundian Netherlands where
the greatest court in Europe in that
period existed and which set the
standards for the Tudor Court and the
French Court to follow standards of
elegance of learning display of
performance etc but scholars have over
the century that this book has been so
widely read talk
that it's part of a cannon in medieval
historiography and has never been
grappled with fully and the other thing
I can say as a teacher and all of us our
teachers our students don't know what to
do with the bunker so we wanted to have
sort of open it up for ourselves and
figure out why it was so important why
so influential in shaping people's
understanding of this period in this
court and yet so intractable for all of
us so the workshop is very productive
because it did two things number one it
helped us understand better what housing
it was up to because it placed him in
his time at the moment of the beginning
of what we call scientific history the
moment when a certain kinds of sources
were privileged and certain kinds of
reading strategies ways to use the
sources what kinds of truths they
revealed that sceptre was becoming
dominant the term that's used in
historiography among historians to talk
about what this method was was that it's
positivist that there's a kind of and
this is a simple definition but a kind
of positive learn information truth that
can come from using certain kinds of
sources responsibly what we learned in
this workshop I think that was most
useful for me and I think for our
students when we teach this book again
is that housing to refuse that method
the what he did instead was choose
different kinds of sources
he chose chronicles which were basically
the newspapers of the age
they were just reports of what was
happening at the court and they were
extremely partisan you think our press
is partisan you have no idea how
partisan this press was they were in the
ploy employee of the court or they were
employed in the employ of
that's right worried of an enemy court
so that you get very biased pictures of
what people were doing that those was
his major form of evidence the other
kind of evidence uses more literary
poems and prose poems that expressed a
lot of the ideals of the period and the
central themes that he worked on were
indeed the notion that this court and
this whole society he deduced from the
performance of the court the way the
society worked was performing a kind of
longing for a certain kind of ideal that
was heroic honorable chivalric that a
world composed of people with high
morals with pure religious beliefs with
the capacity for real spiritual
experiences of cetera and at the same
time ignoring the way they really live
the fact that people killing each other
all the time that the politics were
unstable that in fact this is the
beginning of the Reformation period when
the canons of faith were under attack
all over this region and this is one of
the regions in which the Reformation was
experienced most violently most early
and most radically so what he was trying
to do was to understand what these
ideals were and so he went to the kind
of letter
sure that discussed these ideas and
presented them so his focus was on
performance and on the way performances
were described we use words like ritual
like display etc he didn't really use
those words what he did was to describe
the way these sources portrayed the
court in action so we learned better
what kind of a method that was we also
then spent a lot of time talking about
all the things that he missed that he
was used to talk about that would have
changed the picture I think the major
one was for me anyway and I think for a
lot of people in the room the fact that
this was not only the home of the most
successful Court in the sense of a
courtly culture in this period in Europe
it was also the home of next to northern
Italy but really equal was northern
Italy the most commercially advanced
area of Europe and the time people to
write books about the origins of
capitalism can start here and the
follow-up to this particular moment in
this period this is a this is the period
when blues and antwerpen cities like
that were the New York and the London of
Northern Europe they were followed by AB
ster time and then followed even later
by London but this is the beginning of
that kind of an economy so that's going
on simultaneously and of course the keep
the court lived from that wealth and
actually had never talked about it so we
spent a lot of time thinking why he
didn't talk about it what was the payoff
of not talking
we did have one paper that tried to take
up the question of whether he really
talked about it in a different way I
don't think we were completely convinced
that he really did but I think we
learned to look at his book a little
differently and to think about it not as
a book that was sort of very engaging
because it described the performance of
this court in vivid language overwhelmed
the reader with the details from the
sources that he used one thing one reads
that I had one student who said when he
first read it he was completely baffled
by it you don't know what to make of it
but you're you're beaten down by the
learning of this guy but but we I think
what we learn from this is that he
intended to beat you down he wanted to
make you see that these sources are
telling you about that these
performances were not just performances
they were almost anguished efforts to
not recognize and not deal with what was
going on on the ground around them there
are two ways to think about the
relationship between commerce all these
rich cities that were feeding this court
and and housing those refusal to talk
about it and for the most part the
refusal of the sources he used to talk
about it one way is that they are
denying the fact that in fact this is a
commercialized court the other way to
think about it is is that they are
trying to capture the commercial economy
and make it their own that by display
the way they perform themselves is with
wealth I mean they talk about your
borrowing deeds and
that kind of stuff they have silver
swords and velvet dresses and gold
embossed this etc when you in fact when
you look at the costumes of the late
Middle Ages that the aristocracy wrote
these are the Burgundian constituents
and so that's commercial wealth put on
the bodies of the aristocracy that lived
from this wealth but did not produce it
focusing on one particular book
inevitably implies that one also focuses
on the personality of the author of the
book now Johan Huizinga to some extent
was quite a typical historian at his
time and he was quite different from his
contemporaries not only in the way he
dealt with sources and the problematic
as Marthaville just said but also by his
training and by the several topics he
tackled during his his career originally
he studied sanskrit and he had a great
interest in performances to the courts
of what was then known as the Dutch
Indies present-day Indonesia which also
works well and has an influence on the
way he looks at the provincial court and
the performative aspects of of courtly
life so that's one thing another thing
is that he came almost by accident
because he had to to get into a position
that was free at that moment that
University where he worked when writing
the book the autumn of the middle age
the University of Groningen in the north
of the Netherlands and he had to turn
into a big evil historian he rather
quickly wrote a dissertation on the
sources of the juridical sources and the
political sources of the city of Ireland
and in the province of fault but never
came back to that afterwards so he
really loaded the technical aspects of
medieval history that in the traditional
way of dealing with history who were
ranking high at that same moment instead
of that he wrote his autumn of the
Middle Ages it's very important to be
aware of the fact that the book as we
said is published for the first time in
1990 but that he wrote it during World
War one and somebody one of the
commentators early commentators labelled
it if and a book of remembrance because
he reflects when he deals with the
importance of death of collective death
the plague in the Middle Ages but he
does so when thinking about what's
happening in his own time and we know
that he was very much preoccupied by
all the events that seemed to break away
the whole society Western society as its
presented itself at the end of the 19th
and the beginning of the 20th century
and that seemed to collapse forever in
the course of the First World War so
that's an important think that that has
a direct effect on the tonality and on
the way the book
it is written and if we go back or if we
enlarge the focus and look at the whole
of this scientific production when we
say that that first at the first glance
you have the impression that he helps
from two very different topics he write
two books on America and in which also
he expresses his uneasiness with the
modernity in society that's also
something that can be linked to the the
major theme of the the autumn book he
writes and that was a book that came up
in the workshop time and again a very
interesting book the Homo Luden's on the
element of play as well an individual
life as in society and that has still
has a very as we learned and also
yesterday concrete effect and hyssop
lightest is commented upon in the gaming
industry for instance nowadays and then
in the 30s
he writes two books one book that is
very influential and the title is in the
shadow of tomorrow in which he warns his
contemporaries of what he feels is maybe
the consequences of the new political
order that breaks through and in the 30s
namely fascism in Germany and in Italy
communist totalitarian regime and in the
Soviet unit then again is these books
which were also very influential got
translated into all major languages of
the time gave him the reputation of the
one of the philosophers the ethical
thinkers about what was going on there
in the 30s
that these books are also very much
determined by the same way of looking at
at society and as a change in society
that is already present and in the
waning of the middle age so if you look
at the whole of his career and of his
production there is contrary to what one
might think at the first place maybe
that is really somebody who hops from
one team to another there is more
coherence than one would say at the
first glance